this doesn't just even stop at the
political level this goes all the way up
to the religious level
even the most traditional institution in
the christian west
the catholic church the cult of white
guilt has infiltrated
the catholic church a parishioner i
suppose
recorded this homily i don't know if you
could call it a homily
from a priest at st xavier catholic
church
in new york city who is now engaging in
the liturgy of wokeness
do you support racial justice equity and
compassion in
human relations yes do you affirm that
white privilege is unfair and harmful to
those who have it and to those who do
not
yes do you affirm that white privilege
and the culture of white supremacy must
be dismantled wherever it is present
yes do you support racial equity justice
and liberation for every person
yes do you affirm the inherent worth and
dignity
of every person yes
therefore from this day forward will you
strive to understand more deeply the
injustice and suffering white privilege
and white supremacy cause
yes will you commit to help transform
our
church culture to one that is actively
engaged in seeking racial justice
and equity for all for everyone yes
will you renew and honor this pledge
daily knowing that our church and our
community
our nation and our world will be better
places
because of our efforts yes
i can't say i've ever heard that uh
system of vows in a catholic church what
this is of course i mean
for individual aspects of that nobody
would disagree yeah be nice to people
don't be mean to people
be be a good person don't be a bad
person right
but what this is really describing
is a new and separate and replacement
theology for christianity this is now
the theology
of wokeness you're replacing what may
appear to be one's baptismal vows
with the with now being baptized into
the the waters of wokeness
saying that there are these things white
supremacy white privilege
haven't haven't seen those anywhere i
don't know exactly what
what the priest means by this i know
that we have
one matter of legal racial
discrimination in our country there's
only one matter
where it is legal to discriminate by
race that is called affirmative action
it benefits
black and hispanic applicants for jobs
it disadvantages white and asian
applicants for jobs
that's it show me the other legal white
supremacy
or any legal white supremacy for that
matter show me the the legal racial
discrimination other than affirmative
action
where is it nowhere it doesn't exist
so what is this priest talking about
he has fallen prey to uh
the same thing that i think a lot of our
country has which is
a distraction it's not even
that all this talk about white supremacy
or white privilege or whatever all the
racial division
that seems to be conveniently ginned up
every four years
is it it's not even that it's in good
faith
it's not even that you know maybe some
people who have
good intentions are mistaken it is a
distraction
to distract you from a genuine system of
privilege
and inequity in this country which is
liberal elite privilege liberal elite
privilege which manifests itself in the
media
in politics in the universities in
education for that matter in hollywood
in big tech
there is a liberal established
apparatus that plays by a completely
different set of rules
than you and i play to and it doesn't
matter what color
our skin is it doesn't matter what what
matters is this political distinction
here
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full episode linked in the
description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts